[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
con una declaratoria de emergencia del
gobierno de Nueva York espera responder
a la crisis migratoria en la ciudad la
llegada masiva desde Estados sureños
pone a prueba los sistemas de Refugio
por lo que las autoridades tomaron
medidas de urgencia para albergarlos
pero los migrantes no llegaron por su
cuenta hasta la costa este fueron
trasladados hasta allí en un movimiento
polémico de gobernadores republicanos
para aliviar el peso en sus fronteras y
dejar la responsabilidad en manos de los
demócratas ahora el desafío es para la
acogida en los Estados y ciudades de
destino
una medida de urgencia para responder al
envío de personas desde Estados con
gobiernos republicanos
desde abril al menos 17.000 solicitantes
de asilo llegaron a Nueva York
trasladados desde la frontera Sur según
el alcalde de la ciudad una de cada
cinco personas en su sistema de Refugio
es peticionaria de protección
los alcaldes ya están en la primera
línea de todas las demás crisis que
sufre este país desde la violencia
Armada hasta el cambio climático pero el
gobierno local no puede ser la solución
para las crisis nacionales especialmente
las crisis fabricadas
asegura que los refugios ya funcionan al
100% de su capacidad y teme que las
llegadas sigan aumentando el estado de
emergencia le permite al gobierno local
coordinar esfuerzos para atender la
crisis
como medida urgente ante la falta de
lugares para la acogida la ciudad
instaló carpas de Gran tamaño como
albergues una solución que
organizaciones defensoras de los
migrantes esperan sea transitoria y que
ya genera todo tipo de reacciones
estoy preocupada porque vengo a la playa
los fines de semana con mi perro y llego
a las 7 de la mañana por lo que entiendo
Esto va a estar lleno de personas
solteras y en su mayoría de hombres así
que me preocupa mi seguridad hay muchos
bosques aquí y me pregunto cómo va a ser
vigilado
creo que es algo humanitario creo que la
forma en que se trata a los inmigrantes
debido a algunas cuestiones políticas
está mal todos son humanos merecen tener
un derecho tener una vida digna vengan
de donde vengan
Y es que tres estados Texas Arizona y
Florida de gobernadores republicanos han
fletado autobuses para trasladar a
migrantes hacia regiones lideradas por
demócratas en un movimiento que se da
justo en un año electoral
si hay personas que se inclinan a pensar
que Florida es un buen lugar nuestro
mensaje para ellos es que no somos un
estado santuario y es mejor poder ir a
una jurisdicción santuario Y sí
ayudaremos a facilitar ese transporte
para que puedan ir a pastos más verdes
aseguran que con estos traslados
buscarían aumentar la presión sobre la
casa blanca para que tome medidas ante
la cantidad de extranjeros que cruzan
sus fronteras
la presión no solo recayó en Nueva York
A mediados de septiembre buses fletados
para el mismo objetivo llegaron hasta la
capital estadounidense y sus ocupantes
fueron dejados a las afueras del
observatorio naval donde vive kamala
Harris la vicepresidenta es la designada
por el presidente Joe biden para la
gestión migratoria
variados en Washington frente a la
residencia de la vicepresidenta kamala
Harris estos migrantes llegaron de Texas
después de un largo viaje por
Centroamérica y de 40 horas en buses del
sur hasta la capital estadounidense sale
el 18 de agosto de Venezuela pase por
hacerlo Gracias seis días en la selva en
una experiencia bastante fuerte
una experiencia inolvidable que como
muchos muertos también he visto en la
selva un viaje bastante largo bastante
fuerte y bueno lo que no fue inesperable
fue aquí que nos dejaron a la deriva sin
saber para dónde ir nuestro destino es
llegar hasta Nueva York firmaron sus
traslados con la esperanza de que en
otro estado conseguirían un trabajo y
así empezarían una vida en Estados
Unidos en el caso mío que no tengo
ningún familiar
opté por un bus que estaban saliendo
gratis
para acá y el destino que hubo ese día
era Washington ya yo me vine a
Washington va buscando buscando la
posibilidad de trabajo y salir adelante
como todos pero Defensores de Derechos
Humanos dicen que muchos fueron
engañados con falsas promesas y usados
como arma política
entonces mientras hacemos este
espectáculo político tenemos seres
humanos que sienten que sufrimiento está
siendo explotado han venido a Estados
Unidos a buscar asilo y les han dicho
que se suban a estos buses y les
prometieron que una organización lo
recibiría Aquí les daría comida techo y
trabajo los traslados no están lejos de
las críticas una de ellas por el gasto
público que ha significado Texas habría
destinado hasta agosto casi 13 millones
de dólares para movilizar a los
extranjeros indocumentados
el próximo 8 de noviembre los
estadounidenses van a elecciones de
medio término en las que se definirá
Cómo quedan las fuerzas en el congreso y
son consideradas una especie de
termómetro para el gobierno actual la
migración vuelve como tema de campaña en
el principal país de destino para los
migrantes en el mundo
y el dato de migración de la semana
al menos 3000 migrantes Pasan a diario
por Colombia rumbo al tapón del Darién
El Paso obligado para miles de personas
que cruzan de Sura Centroamérica en
total más de 150 mil migrantes se
internaron en la selva en los primeros
nueve meses de 2022
hasta que migrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]